you worked on both language and vision
what's what's the connection between the
two uh
what's more maybe there's a bunch of
ways to ask this but what's more
difficult
to build from an engineering perspective
and evolutionary perspective
the human language system or the human
vision system or
the equivalent of in the ai space
language and vision
or is it the the best is the multi-task
idea that you're
speaking to that they they need to be
deeply integrated
yeah absolutely i did learning both
at the same time i i think is a
fascinating direction in the future so
you have data sets where there's visual
component as well as
verbal descriptions for instance and and
that way you can learn
a deeper representation a more useful
representation for both
uh but it's still an interesting
question of um
which one is easier eventually i mean
recognizing objects or even
understanding sentences that's
relatively possible
but where it becomes where the
challenges are is to understand the
world
like the visual world the 3d what are
the objects doing and predicting what
will happen
the relationships that's what makes
vision difficult and language obviously
it's it's what's the me what what is
being said what the meaning is
and the meaning doesn't stop at who did
what to whom
um there are goals and plans and themes
and
you eventually have to understand the
entire uh human society and history
in order to understand the sentence very
much fully that
there are plenty of examples of those
kinds of short sentences when you bring
in all the world knowledge
to understand it and that's the big
challenge now
we are far from that but even just
bringing in the visual world
together with the sentence will give you
already a lot deeper understanding
of what's happening and i think that
that's where we're going
very soon i mean we've we've had
imagenet for a long time
and now we have all these text
collections but having both together
uh and then learning a semantic
understanding of what is happening i
think that that will be the
next step in the next few years yeah
you're starting to see that with all the
work with transformers
was the the community the ai community
started to dip their toe into this idea
idea of
having uh language models that are now
doing stuff with images with vision and
then
connecting the two i mean right now it's
like these little explorations we're
literally dipping the toe in
but like maybe at some point we'll just
like dive into the pool
and it'll just be all seen as the same
thing i i do still wonder what's more
fundamental
well their vision is um whether we
don't think about vision correctly maybe
the fact because we're humans and we see
things as beautiful and so on
that and because we have cameras that
taking pixels is a 2d
image that we don't sufficiently think
about
vision as language you know maybe
maybe chomsky is right all along that
vision is fundamental to
uh sorry that language is fundamental to
everything
to even cognition to even consciousness
like the base layers
all language not necessarily like
english but
some weird abstract representation
uh linguistic representation yeah
well earlier we talked about the social
structures and that may be what's
underlying
the language that's the more fundamental
part and then language is being added on
top of that language emerges from the
social interaction
probably yeah that's a very good guess
we are visual animals though a lot of
the brain is dedicated to vision and
also
when we think about various abstract
concepts
uh we usually reduce that to vision uh
and and images and that's
you know go to a whiteboard you draw
pictures of very abstract concepts so we
tend to
tend to resort to that quite a bit and
that's a fundamental representation it's
probably
possible that it predated um you know
language even i mean
animals a lot of they don't talk but
they certainly do have vision
uh and and language is interesting
development in um from for mastication
from eating
you develop an organ that actually can
produce sound to manipulate them
maybe that was an accident maybe that
was something that was available and
and then uh allowed us to to do the
communication or maybe it was
gestures sign language could have been
the original proto-language
we don't quite know but they're the
language is more fundamental than the
medium
in which it's communicated and i think
that it comes from those representations
now in in current
world they are so strongly integrates
it's really hard to say which one is
fundamental
you look at the brain structures and
even visual cortex
which supposed to be very much just
vision well if you are
thinking of semantic concepts you're
thinking of language visual cortex
lights up
it's still useful even for language
computations so there are
common structures underlying them so
utilize what you need
yeah and and and when you are
understanding a scene you're
understanding relationships
well it's not so far from understanding
relationships between words and concepts
so i think that that's how they are
integrated yeah and there's dreams and
once they close our eyes there's still a
world in there somehow operating and
somehow
possibly the visual visual systems
somehow integrate into all the
you